i have an important update for you and
it's something you cannot miss
i'd probably say it's an offer you
cannot refuse you can now prepare for
maths and science starting at just
rupees 249
yes you heard me right just rupees 249.
we are coming up with india's greatest
learning festival called the infinity
learn festival where we will provide you
with the best content at the lowest
prices ever can you believe that you're
getting a host of amazing features like
india's top educators teaching you
through live classes plenty of mock
tests self learned videos by don't
memorize flash cards test series instant
out resolution all of that at such a low
price the sale is live now and the offer
is valid only for a few more days so
what are you waiting for click on the
link in the description head to the
website and purchase your course now